you are you're adventurous as well right
i heard about this trip you took in
alaska which is
crazy i would never i've been to alaska
in a crazy situation but not as crazy as
that
can you tell everybody well it was a it
was a really wonderful trip i went with
my family this was probably
15 years ago it was a it was a
kayaking expedition so we we actually
took these bush planes
into a remote glacier area
and then uh put these collapsible kayaks
together
packed them and then set out for two
weeks just sort of camping on the
on around this bay in water that you can
die from like hypothermia
you would absolutely die if you fell in
the water that it was full of ice
it was like it's like paddling through a
margarita that that's safe
yeah let me jump in this collapsible
well the thing that's actually
surprisingly i that really surprised me
and of course the
the guide has like a rifle in case
there's a bear and stuff like
that i was prepared for but
the glaciers when they calve which is
like when a big
chunk falls off into the water it's one
of the most beautiful things it's really
like this breathtaking
giant event in nature but the sound is
cool
yeah this deep crack crackling
um so we were on uh on the this beach
uh where we were had set up camp and and
we're watching and all of a sudden this
glacier like
that's i don't know maybe half a mile up
the bay but we it's like right in our
view
starts to calve and it's beautiful
everyone's just
jaws open like wide-eyed
and then the guide goes okay run run
run up the hill run up the hill what
what are you talking about
there will be a tsunami let's go let's
go and everyone ran
up the beach to higher ground and sure
enough the calving glacier
kicks off this huge wave wow yeah
um if i'm ever in a remote situation and
the guy that knows what's happening
starts freaking out yelling run yeah
i'd pee my pants and then rest
and then run and run while painting my
pants
i feel like this is how i'm dying great
that's awesome
that's amazing though that you took that
kind of trip that's a that's an amazing
thing to do
yeah like in your life i don't know not
a lot of people get to experience that
no it's truly
i love just getting out into weird
situations i love nature i think it's
very rejuvenating
[Music]
you